[Music]
your favorite athlete closes in for a
victorious win the crowd holds its
breath and at the crucial moment she
misses the shot that competitor just
experienced the phenomenon known as
choking were despite months even years
of practice a person fails right when it
matters most choking is common in sports
where performance often occurs under
intense pressure and depends on key
moments and yet performance anxiety also
haunts public speakers contestants and
spelling bees and even world-famous
musicians most people intuitively blame
it on their nerves but why does being
nervous undermine expert performance
there are two sets of theories which
both say that primarily choking under
pressure boils down to focus first there
are the distraction theories these
suggest that performance suffers when
the mind is preoccupied with worries
doubts or fears instead of focusing its
attention on performing the task at hand
when relevant and irrelevant thoughts
compete for the same attention something
has to give the brain can only process
so much information at once tasks that
challenge working memory the mental
scratchpad we use to temporarily store
phone numbers and grocery lists are
especially vulnerable to pressure in a
2004 study a group of university
students were asked to perform math
problems some easy others more complex
and memory intensive half the students
completed both problem types with
nothing at stake while the others
completed them when calm and under
pressure while everyone did well on the
easy problems those who were stressed
performed worse on the more difficult
memory intensive tasks explicit
monitoring theories make up the second
group of explanations for choking under
pressure they're concerned with how
pressure can cause people to overanalyze
the task at hand here the logic goes
that once a skill becomes automatic
thinking about its precise mechanics
interferes with your ability to do it
tasks we do unconsciously seem to be
most vulnerable to this kind of choking
a study on competitive golf
AFER's compared their performance when
instructed to simply focus on putting as
accurately as possible versus when they
were primed to be acutely aware of the
mechanics of their putting stroke
golfers usually perform this action
subconsciously so those who suddenly
tuned in to the precise details of their
own moves also became worse at making
accurate shots choking may not be
inevitable for everyone though research
suggests that some are more susceptible
than others especially those who are
self-conscious anxious and afraid of
being judged negatively by others so how
can we avoid choking when it really
counts first it helps to practice under
stressful conditions in a study on
expert dart players researchers found
that those who hadn't practiced under
stress performed worse when anxious
compared to those who had become
accustomed to pressure secondly many
performers extol the virtues of a pre
performance routine whether it's taking
a few deep breaths repeating a cue word
or doing a rhythmic sequence of
movements studies on golfing bowling and
water polo find that short rituals can
lead to more consistent and accurate
performance under pressure and thirdly
researchers have shown that having an
external focus on the ultimate goal
works better than an internal focus
where someone is tuned into the
mechanics of what they're doing a study
of experienced golfers revealed that
those who hit chip shots while focused
on the flight of the ball performed
significantly better than those who
focused on the motion of their arms so
perhaps we can modify that age-old
saying practice under pressure with
focus and with that glorious end goal in
sight makes perfect for a nail-biting
example of persevering under pressure we
highly recommend the boys in the boat it
tells the gripping true story of nine
American rowers and their quest for gold
at the 1936 Olympics in Nazi Germany you
can download an audio version of this
book for free at audible.com slash
ted-ed every free trial started through
this link help support Ted's nonprofit
mission